yes and when to welcome to this video
and it's Hagia yo yo yo or this one huh
and we had this on the board a couple of
times I don't know what does he go back
to c4
I placed this okay I think even that we
are on the board okay so let's let's
attack him directly yet we all I'm so
annoyed that he plays the same opening
every single game that I want to want to
just yeah you know let's see Queen h4
that's close to working already
let's do it
c5 I can change I didn't really work
with it it's not the right approach you
should just be happy that you placed
with these bed openings and yeah and and
play normal stuff but I tend to yeah I
tend to not to not do that okay so I can
do this just go for it
and Greg here
check I mean it's not completely
pointless at least yes to defend
now I think precisely and you cannot
play whatever now I think maybe we can
actually take that would be funny
at least that prevents up to six so that
is not a pointless move
yeah which is successor is not
completely harmless you know and see
what it does
9356
not quite sure what I'm doing against
Bishop takes really maybe I just take
you three it's not so terrible
materialized I'm not I'm not material
down here Mac just that I've got to and
pawn and a pawn is not so relevant at
the moment one look is just sitting on a
aid now at least that makes them take a
long think bishop f1 so which is six
that cannot be sold so bad for me so
Bishop g4 got Queen one so what does it
work
but well Queen you want if I just cover
here you still cannot take
yeah so that sacrifice paid off white
resigns yeah I don't know if it really
worked but I kind of felt like doing it
so age five yeah well one thing is he
cannot really take at it that is really
not a good idea that's just good for
black the engine agrees by the way it
even gives h5s the move the energy for
h3 and now night h2 given by the comp
it's interesting
Queen g5 is strong Wow yeah intending to
smash on e3 yeah yeah this is the same
yeah that looks great
okay this also it's not terribly bad
check this and this is can is good for
black Bishop d3 is an interesting move
food that's something I should have
thought about yeah it makes an awful lot
of sense they're attacking this and yeah
this is he cannot do so this is probably
forced the xjx takes and this is very
okay I mean I'm fine material wise and I
still have an attack
okay and this is probably not so great
93 you can take you three I mean it's
still reasonably unclear but I had
better chances perform can that losses
just want the engine is giving okay turn
white is better
and the pieces logo came this was just I
work takes two - oh god it was that was
end of game immediately okay
I mean this is good but not decisive
edges to show it yeah and and and that's
the end wins the full/queen yeah yeah
that she had blundered plundered the
game away I mean it was difficult a is
under under big pressure okay guys
thanks for watching